deep inside the Starbucks headquarters
in Seattle a few feet from CEO Howard
Schultz's desk there's a small lab
filled with rows of glasses and coffee
beans this is the cupping room where a
team of only seven tasters test the
majority of the incoming harvests for
quality Leslie Wolford is one of those
tasters Oh spider monkeys in here people
will walk down the hallway and they say
was that a bird in the cutting process
the first thing we do is we're going to
evaluate the green and then we're going
to roast the coffee we're gonna pour
water off the boil into the cup we're
going to let it sit for three minutes
we're gonna skim the top of it and then
we're going to taste the coffee we're
really looking at the city body
flavor and overall complexity in the cup
so this coffee has a really nice acidity
it's very bright
in the mouth it's very cleansing what
happens if you get a sample in and it's
it's not good we do not take it coffee
is an agricultural product and so just
like anything stuff happens
becoming a Starbucks taster seems
incredibly difficult but Wolford assures
us it's not so hard well that was very
good anyone can taste coffee you just
have to be in it all the time five days
a week we're in here and we're tasting
and calibrating our palates with one
another you can't really talk about
coffee if you don't share with someone
this is a copy to just shoot all day all
day long coffee all day long cotton as
far as quality it's still
yes it's delicious
I can wax poetic but at the end of the
day for me it's just the love of coffee
[Music]